on voulait pas un sujet vous les courses
en parfait état mais un artiste qui sort
qu'à la différence de moi moi j'ai pas
les lunettes de zaza napoli landed dont
je parle où je me tais il est magnifique
il a un charme extraordinaire vous savez
que vous ne se déconsidère ce mode vous
plaisait beaucoup à ma femme et moi et
toi tout plat beau aucune vie sexuelle
par exemple il en avait déjà parlé tout
d'abord il m'a dit ça n'a jamais été mon
fils en plus dense
alors écoutez progiciel savez c'est
comme la tarte à la crème là il faut pas
mettre trop de grèves parce que c'est
nous insisté alors là je me force mais
bon vous êtes toujours le bienvenu ici
d'autant plus aujourd'hui que c'est
votre anniversaire donc je vous dis bon
anniversaire
mais vous êtes au courant de tout de
tout aujourd'hui alors est ce que vous
dites que l'avenir non encore défini
mais il avait tout à fait l'idée des
casseroles c'était clair en cuivre etc
et ce sont les abandons de couper les
chaînes et vendu moi je m'en fous mais
un changement mais on va continuer car
il en remet à demain suivante les impôts
de terre qu'elles sont la table de ma
fille et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux